yeah
merry christmas to you too story time
yesterday was one of those days you know
those days happens once in a blue moon
where you just do nothing i laid in my
bed for 12 hours and i listen to music
it's kind of amazing i wouldn't suggest
doing that every day that's not an
everyday thing but once in a blue moon
oh it felt good to do that but i knew
today i needed to give back and i was
like okay video what to do
and i ran across home sweet home alone
and i was like morbid curiosity hook man
i need to see what all the fuss was
about heard it was terrible but i kind
of need to see for myself
and now here i am
a broken man but i do have a theory here
it is i think by the end of this class
and also uh this is a really good scotch
if you're looking for a scotch that's
smoky kind of like a campfire meets a
leather-bound book it's quite good but i
think by the end of this glass
this movie will start making a lot more
sense or at least it's very existence
that's now plagued humanity but hey
santa scotch has arrived so
let's review
[Music]
so home sweet home loan is actually a
movie
in concept
it could have been quite good actually
quite excellent it could have been a
great take on the home alone formula but
flipped so home sweet home alone could
have been a great flip because it's not
a kid who was left home alone for
christmas
and now these bandits are gonna break
into his house and steal his things and
it's his house he has a defendant no
home sweet home alone was a kid who was
left home alone for christmas and then
this family this couple who also have
kids are in dire financial straits and
they need to sell their house and they
find out that they own this doll that's
worth two hundred thousand dollars it
would really help them but the doll's
not there and since they were selling
their house they suspect someone who was
at the open house when they were showing
off their house stole it and the kid was
the only one who saw it so they're like
obviously the kids stole the doll so
we're gonna break into that house and
steal our property back which is why i
say this could have been a cool take on
the home alone formula instead of having
this kid who's this innocent and these
bandits who are dicks and they come in
and try to steal his stuff you could
have this other psychopath kid if i'm
gonna mention another mcculloch culkin
property the good son it's like they're
breaking into the good son's house who
stole their property so the bandits are
actually the good guys and the kids a
little psychopath and you know so you
could be rooting for the bandits this
time that could definitely work if it
were you know written and executed well
also not called home alone don't make it
a home alone property make it this
smaller movie maybe debut it at a film
festival and then you could have the
critic praise when the trailer comes out
to the masses after the film festival
where critics will be like oh it's like
home alone with the dark twist and i
don't know about you but i'd be like
that sounds interesting kind of want to
see it but no because this movie wants
to ride the coattails of home alone you
hear that in the musical score the
musical score throws back to the john
williams score so it sounds familiar it
has that self-aware moment that i've
seen more movies like this do where they
it's a remake and they know it sucks so
they have to have the self-aware moment
one of the cast members you know one of
the characters they go why do they try
to do remakes you're never as good as
the original it's like i see what you're
doing you're trying to soften the blow
don't soften the blow you know your
movie sucks that's why you said that
manipulative i tell you but the home
invasion part sucked too it's not
imaginative the original home alone
there was a charming simplicity of them
slipping on micro machines then home
alone two they were like all right let's
do everything bigger i'm not gonna lie
child jeremy in the movie theater
i had never laughed so hard in a movie
theater than when marv is getting
pummeled with bricks that kevin's
throwing from the roof
what can i say i was laughing really
hard in that movie theater i never
laughed in this movie like a chuckle
here and there sure but it was more of a
pity chuckle just like in the way that
they slip on the driveway and they're
sliding back she's like this is not
working out but it was just a chuckle
like if this was in practical jokers and
they were doing that thing like hey try
not to laugh whatever chuckle i gave
wouldn't have constituted a laugh i
wouldn't have lost the challenge it's a
weird reference to me whatever it's
working but also there's no sense of
them actually making headway and getting
into the house if they spend so much
time on the driveway just trying to get
to the house also the kid just ices the
entire street leading to his house i'm
like you didn't think that through i
mean home alone law says
the house the property anything in the
property that's fair game but if you ice
the street yeah it made them crash could
have made any of your neighbors crash
too then you'd be in a world of
financial shed or at least your parents
would then when the dude finally gets to
the porch there's these milk and cookies
that are laid out there like dear santa
he's like oh don't mind if i do i'm like
okay now i'm officially not rooting for
you guys either because you're idiots
why would you eat cookies and drink the
milk of the house you're breaking into
why would you do that it's just light
don't of course they had red hot peppers
in there and so burned his mouth but
that's why you don't do that tell you
what i feel bad for the kid in this
movie like the actor
he was great in jojo rabbit archie yates
he was a standout and jojo rabbit he was
a great pick
for a kid in a home alone movie how did
his agent convince him to do this you
know poor kid probably didn't know it's
home alone was huge in the early 90s and
have been
well home alone 3 was theatrical but
since then been straight to dvd [ __ ]
since instances like this always feel
bad for the kid actors who are having
the time of their lives i hope that he
knows that the hate that this movie's
getting has nothing to do with him it's
the studio in that soulless
cash grab mentality that was this
movie's inception
that has nothing to do with him archie
yates we love you so i'm rooting for him
archie yates this is for you rooting for
you buddy home sweet home alone quite
simply is the sign of the times my
friends it's that new installment of a
movie that became a franchise that was
just supposed to be a couple of movies
does all the cheap tricks to
nostalgically link it to the originals
but doesn't have an original thought in
its entire [ __ ] horrid script the
biggest problem with this movie is i
wasn't rooting for anybody i wasn't
rooting for the kid
because i wasn't attached to the family
like the glue that held the original
home alone movies together you know that
family element that fell short in this
movie so i didn't care about the family
i didn't care about anyone in the family
so i didn't care about the kid so at
that point i was like all right let's
root for the ones breaking into the
house because they are essentially
trying to get their property back but
they go about it like idiots so i'm not
rooting for them either so i'm rooting
for nobody in this movie because the
movie fell short where it just couldn't
fall short and that is to justify its
own existence it never did home sweet
home alone didn't have the heart that
the original home alone movies had it
didn't have the laughs that the original
home alone movies had if you're going to
watch a home alone movie just watch the
original home alone movies they still
exist and they're enjoyable as hell ever
do that thing where it's a streaming
service you're like how much more to god
we're only half through okay i did that
i did that with this one i heard it was
dog [ __ ] what can i say the internet
remains undefeated it is actually
telling of streaming services and what
those can do
for bad movies you know there's some
sort of cinematic camouflage going on it
used to be theatrical movies yeah they
could be good they could be [ __ ] but
theatrical films they were distinctly
separated from straight to dvd films you
know they felt completely different but
now a movie can come straight to
streaming service so it leaves the
audience thinking like well is this a
straight to dvd movie that got a
streaming release or is this a would be
theatrical release that got a streaming
service release because of the kovid
times we don't really know so [ __ ] like
this gets mixed into the forefront you
start hearing more chatter about this
movie when under normal circumstances
you wouldn't have heard about this movie
at all would have been straight to dvds
straight to the walmart bin and no one
would have been any the wiser and here
we are and now we watch it or you don't
watch it i watch it i take that hit for
you merry christmas all right so home
sweet home alone have you seen it
no you haven't but hey it's december
it's christmas it's the holidays so
what's your favorite holiday movie the
one that you watch every holiday season
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
permission to come aboard